[Music]
I've decided to eliminate
[Music]
no one
[Music]
all four of you are moving forward to
the grand finale of RuPaul's Drag Race
all right top four how's it feeling it
feels great I mean we have worked
obviously so hard this has been such an
incredible season with like the craziest
challenges the craziest queens and to
finally be here after waiting for so
long is very validating and it's it's
just I could not be more excited I don't
sound very excited but it's all
contained and of course set but I am
like screaming on the inside screaming
on the inside yes of course very aquaria
to scream on the inside right turning
shunting pretty I'm the best from New
York City playing at the parties and I
know that I am carrying a maybe an
Aquarian but it's it's a great
opportunity to be representing all of
season 10 here with aquaria Eureka and
Cameron and you know it's it's a great
villain to have made at this one
[Music]
honestly I'm just happy to be here I'm
so honored I mean the journey I've been
on to be able to become from going home
for to being in the top four is like
it's amazing believe it I am actually
here and I'm really excited for tonight
you had some mixed feelings about
sending people home I mean they're my
sisters I would not want to be in that
position of sending people home but at
the end of the day it is a competition
am I happy I'm still here of course what
I want them here with me yes but it's
hop forward it can only be for people
and I'm glad that I'm where town now
here I am with mamoru American just like
you
[Music]
[Applause]